[Music]
something that is useful to know about
mit is that um it's like drinking from a
fire hose
they will often tell you about this in
tours and everything too but you really
get to experience it when you first
start your classes
so there's lots of great research to do
at mit a lot of great classes to take as
well but i think what maybe some people
don't know about is that there's lots of
really cool
um activities you can get involved with
there's a sailing club you can do rowing
there's any hundred
uh any number of different activities
you can get involved with while you're
here any people should know that mit has
a lot to offer which means that you'll
have
lots of classes lots of
extracurriculars lots of sports options
and so that means that basically you can
be overwhelmed with the number of things
going on and just to kind of pick and
choose drink them all in but be choosy
about what you should what you should do
with your time and what you should work
on
the people here are really great and i
think that
the people are sort of what makes this
place special so not only sort of my
experience not only are people here
obviously really smart but i think
they're also super down to earth uh very
easy to sort of talk to and have
conversations with not just about
academics but also stuff outside of that
and so i found that it's uh actually
been a surprisingly sort of balanced
place in terms of uh just interests and
um and also i think that uh
you know a lot of people here
because they sort of are so passionate
about what they do and love what they do
so much they're always happy to to talk
about it and sort of want to have
conversations about it so i think people
may sometimes be intimidated
but i would say like yeah don't be
intimidated and sort of like talking to
people and um yeah everyone i think is
is
in general quite welcoming around here
well mit is a super collaborative
environment so
do not hesitate to
reach out to people around you and
you know explore
any potential future projects that you
could work on together because
everyone has a unique expertise so by
working together you can achieve greater
things so i think that there are things
that i could say related to coursework
or to you know
the intellectual inquiry that you'll do
and how to think about research but i
think what maybe is more important than
any of that to your long-term success in
the program
is
finding a group of people that you
resonate with and i think sometimes
people come in
to the program and they kind of get in a
local minima where they're surrounded by
a certain type of people and they think
that this is true for the rest of the
community and that's not the case and
you can find people that will
you know resonate with you and make you
feel like you're growing and learning in
the right ways and make you feel like
you belong and so if you're interacting
with people that don't make you feel
like you belong
there's someone else that you can work
with i think it's really really
important that you know how to take care
of yourself so if you come to mit you
need to find a support network and you
need to rely on those people because
it's going to be hard if you come here
that's the nature of the work that we're
doing and it's the nature of the
institute and so finding those friends
finding those people you can rely on uh
that will get you through
it's cold
but you can deal with it you know it
takes a little bit of suffering
tolerance
[Music]